wir stehen in philadelphia vor dem
rathaus im zentrum von philadelphia wo
die nationalgarde aufmarschiert ist
dramatische momente heute morgen hamm
wies und busse sind durch die stadt
gefahren und dann waren diese soldaten
auf einmal da mit sturmgewehren mit
uniformen
sie haben ihre kampf helme auf und sie
sollen jetzt hier also in den nächsten
stunden und tagen du hast es gesagt noch
14 tage bis zu es war für sicherheit und
für ruhe sorgen
der präsident fordert jetzt ein härteres
vorgehen der behörden vor ort wie
reagieren die menschen wie reagieren die
potenziellen wähler auf diese äußerungen
des präsidenten
also es gibt natürlich wie so oft in den
usa zwei lager das eine lager ist auf
der seite der demonstranten
die sagen was hier passiert in den usa
das geht so nicht weiter und auf der
anderen seite die leute die sagen
politischer protest schön und gut aber
plündern polizei die polizisten
angreifen polizei autos anzünden das
geht überhaupt nicht was jetzt diese
bilder diese soldaten aber hier machen
werden mit der stadt und den menschen
das lässt sich noch gar nicht absehen
denn eins ist wichtig in den vergangenen
24 stunden da war es hier eigentlich
ruhig die polizei hat nämlich schon in
der nacht den gesamte innenstadt
abgesperrt hier ging gar nichts mehr
hat straßensperren errichtet wie man das
sonst aus kriegs und krisengebieten
errichtet da dachte man eigentlich die
situation ist beruhigt die plündereien
waren vorbei und trotzdem kam jetzt hier
heute morgen diese männer und frauen in
uniform und soll der zusätzliche
verstärkung dienen
sie sollen als verstärkung dienen
bei anderen protesten diese auch nach
tödlichen vorfällen gab da war der
einsatz der nationalgarde dann doch eher
ein brandbeschleuniger wie glaubst du
wird sich die situation bei dir in der
letzte stattfindenden achte bei dir vor
ort entwickeln ja was versprichst du was
total wichtig ist und richtig ist an
diese bäder diese diese show of force
das hat in der vergangenheit oft
provoziert das hat erst recht leute auf
die straße gelockt da gibt es im
internet schon aufrufe
da geht es darum die eigene stadt
zurückzuholen zurückzuerobern
und dazu muss man sagen in den letzten
24 stunden ist hier sind hier die
ausläufer eines hurricanes durchgezogen
es hat wahnsinnig geregnet es ist
wahnsinnig kalt das alles hat leute von
den straßen abgehalten aber ab morgen
soll es wieder wärmer werden das besser
das wetter besser werden und was das
wochenende
diese bilder hinter mir dass das mit der
gemengelage hier in philadelphia macht
das wird sicherlich spannend und da wenn
wir genau hinschauen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren